it's not true that people don't talk
about these things we all do we don't
want them talked about no that's not
true if you wanted to cancel no malcolm
i'm sorry you're lying that's fine
it is lying i not only have i've
personally talked about many of the
things that you just mentioned i define
critical critical race theory by citing
the actual authors of critical race
theory and you seem to be a pretty good
beneficiary of the meritocracy because
you have merit malcolm so if you're
going to criticize the meritocracy
there's an outgrowth of white supremacy
then you're going to have to tear down
the system that you've succeeded in
because you have merit or do not have
merit you know when my great great
grandfather ran away from slavery to
join the 111th u.s colored troops and
fight
against the south keeping human beings
as slaves he didn't think you know what
in 150 years my great-great-grandson's
gonna have to sit on stage and argue
with a guy who thinks all that's
all right
[Applause]
i'm just saying
there is no controversy the controversy
that's made up is people saying that
this is being discussed this is being
taught in schools and that kids should
be getting that's not true it's not even
a real controversy
the fifth largest school district in
america clark county just decided that
they were going to lower standards with
regard to testing because they wanted to
alleviate disparities in outcomes that
is an outgrowth of critical race theory
can you draw a straight line to it yes
100 because when you say that the
meritocracy is an outgrowth of white
supremacy and then you suggest that i'm
somehow denying that slavery took place
or that your great great great
grandfather was a hero because i'm
saying that i want people tested when
they are in school to see if they are
good at school
but i think it's also a leap to say that
he thought that was
because that's not what it is i mean
we're talking are we talking about 2021
are we talking about 1861